I'm about to say something I never
thought I would about Bill bich he's on
the hot seat and if you don't believe me
I have three stats that prove it number
one bill bich suffered the worst loss of
his career in week four and then
suffered the second worst loss of his
career one week later before that he
only lost by 30 points or more once in
the regular season as the Pats head
coach number two the Patriots are 1 in4
that's the worst start for Bill bich
since 2000 before Tom Brady threw his
first pass and this last one might be
the most damning Bill bich became the
Pats head coach in 2000 in his career
he's lost 24 home games with Tom Brady
he's lost 25 games at home without Tom
Brady look belich is a legend and he
probably won't be fired tomorrow but if
bel's job's in trouble there's something
big he might miss out on he currently
needs 30 wins to pass Don Schuler for
the most wins all time for an NFL coach
and while he might have been a locked to
get there just a few seasons ago belich
might lose his chance at the record and
lose his job